[Musique]
là on a une machine qui coule entre 20
et 30 millions d'euros en cas de rupture
de d'approvisionnement électrique
soudain on pourra avoir les machines qui
restent bloquée en bas impossibilité de
redémarrer avant plusieurs heures voire
plusieurs jours donc on peut pas prendre
ce risque s'il risque de coupure pour
qu'on l'arrête vraiment
[Musique]
nous sommes procurés les rapports mis à
disposition par RTI quand nous avons
consulté dedans étaient indiqués un
certain nombre de semaines plus
critiques et donc nous avons décidé de
réorganiser l'usine en termes d'horaire
de production pour écrêter s'effacer du
réseau sur ces semaines vu critiques par
RT nous quand on s'efface du réseau on
enlève la consommation de l'équivalent
de 1000 foyers donc c'est substantiel
[Musique]
je suis mitigé plutôt
content parce que bon forcément ça fait
un petit peu plus sur la paye mais moi
ça va j'ai de la chance parce que j'ai
mon grand-père qui te garder les enfants
mais si c'est pour une nourrice ben en
fait on les mettrai pour la nourriture
tant que ça reste sur une courte période
pour pouvoir continuer à travailler je
veux personnellement je viens je veux
bien le faire mais
c'est regrettable quand même quand c'est
pas des horaires qui sont normaux
[Musique]